behind me is a group of protesters uh
deliberating on what to do next actually
a lot of them told me that they they
weren't sure why they decided to storm
the building but now that they have they
are now deliberating on what this day or
not but I think they're moving issuing a
statement from inside let's go is to the
public so in that sense they might not
be alienating the something altogether
so that's interesting so they haven't
come in here with a particular aim their
aim was just to just to get in that we
know that there isn't going to be any
legislative business tomorrow so there
is a possibility that perhaps these
protesters around you could simply just
go home as you can see now there's not a
lot of protesters inside the chamber a
lot of people in yellow vests are
actually press so many have already left
the chamber and also the less computing
because we just see if this if it's the
is stabilized he's back sorry some we
lost a little bit what you were saying
you were telling us that a lot of the
people that we can see in the LMS
suppress a lot of the protesters have
already left how many would you estimate
are still there
I'd say in the chambers my colleagues
have told me that of them actually
retreated outside into a protest zone
outside the Legislative Council okay I
think we are gonna have to leave it
because of the really bad signal but but
some lucky it is good to talk to you
interesting what he was saying there
that the protesters broke in they
weren't quite sure what they were going
to do when they got in there now they've
got in there they are now discussing
what they are going to do that a lot of
them have actually left the building
already so whether or not the rest of
them simply decide to do the same thing
we will simply have to wait and see